and
here we go
people have to let me know
when they can see
and hear me
oh that's hot
that's hot and um
potent
ah
it is cider it is indeed cider
may not be only cider but it's cider
ah
forgot I had this tab open waiting
I didn't mean to scare you Matthew
so Mouse under my bathroom sink last
night I had to kill it that ah that
unfortunately is kind of what you have
to do with mice
like if you can get them in a no kill
trap like cool but
sometimes yeah
a happy birthday Logan very nice
you you survived another complete trip
around the Sun
cake
clean this off a little bit
I hope everyone's doing all right
I don't have uh
specific Topic in mind we're kind of in
a weird
middle Zone the uh midterms are mostly
behind us
coming up on Thanksgiving
um or at the very least Thanksgiving
will happen between this stream and the
next one so
yeah time
it does its thing
yeah I don't know how how eloquent I'm
gonna be tonight
I watched Kevin Conroy's last
performance as Batman today rest in
peace yeah oh that was um
that was a bummer
ended up watching enemy of the world
last night Trenton does not get enough
love it's true he doesn't yeah
I feel like
I I think part of that might be because
like Cardinal gets a lot of love by
default by being the first
pertwe is uh in living memory for a lot
more people partly because you know he
didn't have any lost stuff the way uh
Hartnell and trouten did like Harlem
Troutman were handicapped by the um
by the fact that a lot of their stuff
was missing but trouton got more Love by
default for being number one
should we start calling David Tennant
the Grover Cleveland doctor
we could I just don't know how many
people you'd have to end up explaining
that to though and those are the those
are the best forms of shorthand the kind
you must explain
John vinyls thank you very much for the
Super Chat my friend thoughts on dead
end paranormal Park and The Ghost and
Molly McGee so far okay
um I have shot a review for the first
season of dead end paranormal Park
that'll be coming out
later this month I don't know exactly
when uh goes to Molly McGee I didn't do
a full review for just because I don't
have enough thoughts about it
it's fun
I I like it the kiddo likes it
but it's uh it's probably the most
disposable of the stuff that that we've
watched together there just isn't like
it's it's fun
that's it's kind of all I got uh I've
got a lot more thoughts on dead end but
like I said there is a full review
coming out for that one
um short version it took me a little
while to get up to speed with how
fast-paced it is like honestly the pace
at which it moves it feels more like a
season two than a season one but if you
what if you pass that it's quite good
uh can you ask if chat got it
I suppose I suppose I can
um there was the joke made a little bit
ago
um whether we should start calling David
Tennant the uh the grow the new David
Tennant Incarnation the Grover Cleveland
doctor or just tenant in general do
people actually get that
do they have what
do they understand what that means I
don't know
I have a kid
it's always funny the people who have
who have missed that they're always
super shocked by the fact that I have a
kid yes I have had a kid for longer than
I've had uh the Council of Geeks YouTube
channel so yes I have a kid
foreign
did you see Miriam Margolis was going to
be in the 60th I did not see that I
missed that
question that's been bugging me is
what does it mean for uh a character is
edgy because most characters most people
see as edgy I see as tragic
um
I
I think it has to do with the intent
like most edgy characters have tragic
elements but but it's like what was that
in service of was it in service of
giving them depth Humanity or was it in
service of making them cold in a cold
world and I'm too hard for all the
meanness out there
I edgy is less about specific things
that have happened to a character and
more about
affectation and aesthetic and atmosphere
around a character if that makes sense
Supremo Mega
thank you so very much
for the Super Chat been reading 80s and
90s post-crisis Batman I miss when the
bat family was smaller what it was just
Bruce Alfred Tim Oracle and occasionally
Nightwing
um I get I get the appeal video of that
like
I think
it really would help if more members of
the bat family would spread their rings
and leave Gotham like dick did with
bloodhaven except they eventually kind
of brought him back
um yeah
it does eventually get to the point
where it's like Batman Bruce
have you considered retiring
you've got like 12 Replacements even if
they're not as good as you I think they
can pick up the slack
uh however consider ranking the
apocryphal doctors such as David Bradley
Richard hurdle uh herndl Peter Cushing
Richard E Grandin the Unbound ones
um probably not if only because
the views would uh would absolutely tank
um I'm like
if I did it I'd have to do it in a way
that would be super low effort because
like No One's Gonna know what I'm on
about
um
plus I really I I really I haven't
gotten to all the Unbound ones
um and I really need to re-watch uh
scream of Ashoka I will do a video on
that eventually it'll be in the break
room but
excuse me
um I I will get to that
how am I I'm doing okay I'm doing all
right
um
I don't know Rowan I might still do it
maybe not a ranking maybe just a rundown
of like all the all of the non-canon
doctors
they're
there's probably something there I'd
like I'd have I'd have to think about it
and I also need to get more Unbound
stuff
uh
um it was earlier than that Ms Wicked
Wolf when I
started
um
using the spicy website
I think it was about a year ago
when it went from sort of early preview
stat state to you know
doing it properly
for lack of a better way to put it
scream of the Shocker was retconned into
being Unbound wasn't it I don't know I
I don't know how Canon has dealt with
that I assumed they just ignored it
reviewed pet cemetery on my channel
recently in honor of my pup my crop who
passed away Ong also contains cat
footage plug plug now which pet cemetery
vacuum of comments the first movie or
the newer one
I have to cook before my brain implodes
see you later okay em uh
go get some food
uh I've also been looking at Jane Stu's
videos of them running uh Doctor Who
with Alan Rickman as the doctor and I
legit can't unsee it now I have I
haven't gone through all this stuff like
they're they're a lot of their stuff
that they record it goes on for a while
like and that's no bad thing but like
you know
the amount of free time or even vague
approximations of free time I have are
Slim
if I can offer my thoughts on some of
the things Jeff Johns did in DC
specifically switching Wally and Barry I
can get why people would be ticked about
it
I don't even really care about the Flash
just on principle
I think what Jeff Johns did was
really selfish
really creatively selfish
and uh I think it was kind of a dick
for it I didn't think too much on it
when it happened but as I've gotten
older and I've really thought about it
I'm like ah
um
no no I'm really not I really am not
okay with it actually
aha neither I reviewed the book Pat
Cemetery Michael C Hall did the
audiobook oh oh he could do that well I
would imagine
kind of felt bad killing the mouse
because it was freezing outside I mean
like I get why mice take up residents
and houses especially as it gets colder
but like
this is not your place dude and if I let
you stay your friends are gonna show up
real quick
on the other hand Wally was incredibly
overpowered in his time yeah but there
are ways to Nerf a character without
freaking erasing them
like that's an if that
first of all first of all John's never
claimed that was what he was trying to
address at least not that I ever saw
and even if he was that's a massive over
correction
so
you know
busy playing Street Fighter Alpha 3 but
I thought I'd come by and say hi to Vera
and friends it's always nice to see you
oh thanks Jeffrey have fun
um I haven't really
I used to play Street Fighter 2 a lot I
haven't really played that series since
Street Fighter 2 Championship Edition oh
geez I'm old
uh when I came up with that joke I
thought uh hope the Trump doctor won't
end up working too but after the
midterms I don't think that'll happen
for the that'll happen for the first
time agree
ah all right so
taking a moment to dip into the midterms
real quick
I think what has become very clear is
that the
the GOP the Republicans are very much
um
in a struggle
because you've got Trump still trying to
hold on but that's clearly not working
because
a really high percentage of the
candidates he personally endorsed they
won their primaries but then lost the
general election so that sends a
resounding signal to anyone who is not
just a trump loyalist
um that he is not a winning ticket
um so that means that anyone who has not
completely swallowed the Kool-Aid who
either was either just tolerating him or
was an opportunist who was just trying
to write his code Tales is quickly
abandoning him because it doesn't seem
advantageous anymore so that's one thing
that's going on you have Ron DeSantis
who's basically trying to co-opt or at
least Splinter off
um some of Trump's base and ride that to
a nomination
and then you have the old school
Republicans who would real he probably
prefer to not have either of those guys
but will happily put up with them
um if they think they have a chance at
winning but right now there's a lot of
struggle
here's here's the thing
the Republican party is dealing with the
fact that right now
most of what they stand for what they
want to accomplish
people don't want
they want to prevent any additional gun
control the vast majority of people want
some additional gun control they helped
undo Roe v Wade the majority of this
country wants abortion rights they're
going after queer people and while in
certain States they're getting away with
it on the whole nationally most uh
people are in favor of queer rights as
human rights they are
um trying to argue in favor of their
Economic Policy but they spent 40 years
um cutting taxes on the rich and
everybody else is still screwed nobody's
really swallowing that anymore
the things that they're selling
um people don't want
and they've tried lying about it they've
tried doing a lot of stuff
uh over the years and it's not working
as well Trump actually kind of got them
in that we got them in trouble because
Trump trump always had the quiet Parts
out loud
so once Trump was there the mass came
off and very blatantly a lot of what
they were trying to do and it woke a lot
of a lot of people up I think in terms
of
you know your centrists and I don't have
a lot of use for Centris to be clear
but
um right now the the Republican well
honestly
for the last 20 years the Republicans
have been fighting against the fact that
what they want to do is not something
people want
people haven't really wanted what the
Republicans have been selling since Bush
won
um and
it's uh it's really starting to catch up
with them I mean it's why there was all
the election denial they need to
suppress the vote because if everybody
eligible to vote votes they lose
they just do now this is me slamming the
Republicans and not necessarily praising
the Democrats because
they do
I'll still say that they are what should
be voted for for the simple reason that
um
you know
if you're giving me a choice between
someone who is failing to help me and
somebody who is actively trying to hurt
me
that's not a hard choice to make but it
doesn't mean I like the people who are
failing to help
John vinyls once again with the Super
Chat thank you so very much theory that
in addition to wit heart and strength
the Calamity Trio of amphibia
um also represent different forms of
intelligence with Marcy being in
intellect knowledge Sasha being
adaptability and and being empathy
that tracks oh that definitely tracks
I'd like immediately I thought well
Anne's empathy I wasn't sure I wouldn't
have known what to put Sasha down as but
yeah adaptability fits very well for her
actually
my my voice is angelic
that's
that's that's so that's a little much I
think
I'm just going to jump crap
jump tracks real quick I saw a true
romance with my sister recently and I
really liked also Val Kilmer as the king
is amazing casting I've seen bits and
pieces of True Romance
um
I haven't seen that movie start to
finish
I've kind of fallen off Tarantino not
that I've like not that I think he's bad
um but I think whatever part of me there
was that connected with his work is just
not as much a part of me anymore
I can't even see the positives of being
in the Republican Party these days
really well
if you're rich the positives are they
enable you to hoard your wealth and make
even more simply by virtue of the fact
that you're already rich
and if you're not rich but you really
hate liberals
yeah that seems to be the uh the two
main selling points
yeah
that's the problem when you have only
two parties to choose from two cheeks of
the same ours yeah the two-party system
is kind of inherently broken because
if the parties never refresh
if neither party either goes through a
major change or gets replaced by
something else
or a viable third party happens if none
of those things happen then what is just
going to naturally occur over time
is that each side on nearly every issue
not absolutely every but nearly every
issue are simply going to take up the
opposite positions
because
at a certain point
the what makes the most sense is to try
and gather up whatever voters
are on the opposite side of what your
opponents are doing and there's no
benefit to being in the middle anymore
because if
uh one side is is pushing
um you know for one thing really really
hard and you're like well you know I'm
kind of iffy about it people are you're
just wishy-washy it feels like you're
not taking a stand people are gonna go
on the other side but the the outcome of
that
is that people have to basically kind of
they have to prioritize their morals and
their principles
so to pull the example of say for
instance the um
the so-called Log Cabin Republicans
which was a bunch of uh CIS uh white
guys
who were gay but otherwise all of their
policies aligned with Republicans they
just wanted the Republicans to stop
trying to outlaw gay marriage that was
back when the uh Log Cabin Republicans
were a bit more of a thing I don't have
really of use for them but I do have a
Little Bit of Sympathy in so far as
they were put they they work as an
example of a group that had to basically
go look we agree with you on all these
things except for this thing
so we either have to back you regardless
and sacrifice this principle or we
sacrifice all these
does this one mean more than all these
do all these mean more than this
so like to just go other ways
if you have somebody who is fiscally
conservative
but socially liberal
you know someone who wants to
um tighten the budgets have lower taxes
lower spending but also believes in
securing queer rights abortion rights
Etc
um
what are they supposed to do
you either go with a fiscal conservative
and sacrifice all your social values or
you go with social liberals and
sacrifice all your fiscal values
forcing people into a position where
they have no choice but to sacrifice
some of their principles
a lot of them will ignore the fact that
they're doing that
and some of them
will alter their principles so that
everything aligns
and neither is a great thing for a
person or for
a nation
super chats let's see high voltage thank
you very much
to answer your question in the happiness
Patrol review they got away with the
politics mainly because the BBC didn't
care enough about the show to scrutinize
it also Sun makers is super political I
think carowind already pointed out in
the chat we are going to do sun makers
as we get to tax season here in the U.S
but uh yeah that does make sense if
anyone didn't see it already
um I did a review for the Seventh Doctor
Story the happiness Patrol
uh over in over in the break room of
Geeks and
holy
holy crap that they
insane how politically pointed it is
it's also really good so
um I recommend that in general and I do
recommend
um maybe seeing the review too if you
haven't as well
apology is if this was already mentioned
rest in peace Kevin come right it was
mentioned Sammy but yes it nothing wrong
with reiterating it
uh let's see Supreme
Omega thank you for the Super Chat bat
fam thoughts on Tim Drake and how he has
been sidelined more and more because DC
wants to push Damien in the Red Hood in
both comics and other media thoughts
it's a waste
it's a waste Damien is real boring to me
um and I also think Jason Todd should
have stayed dead
Tim Drake was a really interesting Robin
because when he started
he was there voluntarily he wasn't an
orphan he had a home life he was a
well-adjusted kid
and that is interesting because of how
that contrasts with who Batman is
because Batman especially as he's been
written in the last 30 years is dark and
broken and all that nonsense so having a
robin that is that basically has his
life more put together than Batman does
that's a really good dynamic
Damian is an insufferable little turd
and Jason was way more interesting when
he was dead so sidelining Tim for those
two dipsticks no that's a waste
have I seen Black Adam yet I have not
um when the reviews came out and were as
tepid as they were I just didn't have a
particularly
strong impetus to rush out to the
theater I'll probably catch it when I
start streaming but um no I haven't seen
it yet it's not high on my priority list
at the moment
and GP thank you very much for the Super
Chat I've heard Hassan Minaj say we
can't get any viable third parties
unless we get on board with a ranked
Choice voting I found that interesting
and disheartening it is
probably true
because the
um
the most effective third-party candidate
in uh modern history possibly all
history
was Ross Perot he was big enough to
actually get a spot in the televised
debates the presidential debates
but
he
couldn't secure a single
um
uh what the hell's the word
electoral vote that stupid thing that we
haven't gotten rid of yet
um
so yeah I think
I I don't think it'll suddenly guarantee
we'll have a third party I think it will
increase the odds that we'll get one if
ranked Choice voting becomes standard
unfortunately ranked Choice voting
uh is a state-by-state thing so
you'd be looking at a very slow burn
because States run their own elections
and as a result you'd have to get every
state to do it and what will probably
happen is we're looking at decades and
decades
for a change to happen because ranked
Choice voting would give third party
candidates a more viable place
um in the states that have it and if
they can start doing well enough in
those States maybe it gives them
you know enough of a platform to have a
foothold elsewhere or maybe they just
become a super local thing
I don't know it's gonna be a while
forever I actually shot my review
earlier today that should be up
Thursday
I'll have that up because tomorrow I
have to do the Andor review or maybe
I'll do it tomorrow and do Android
Thursday I don't know
I don't know it'll be
it'll be up in the next couple days
foreign
my age liked him but I was too young to
vote
my parents thought Ross Pro was an utter
ass I had no particular love for the man
uh personally but like just factually he
was the closest we had to a viable Third
Party candidate
Doctor Who spin-offs in future if so
what
I'm a real bad person to ask
cause my hook into Doctor Who is the
doctor
like as a character
I don't have a lot of interests in
spin-offs I just don't
and like I'm not saying they shouldn't
exist or that they're bad for the show
um necessarily but they're just they're
not where my interests are
so I'm I'm a bad person to ask I'm not
closed off to them I'm not saying never
do it but I just don't have any inherent
interest I'd probably try some of them
out if they end up happening which they
probably will
um but like I have no expectations or
hopes or really anything I'm just like
okay we're doing that now I guess
I pointed this out on Twitter when he
passed away but the main villain and the
sun makers also played the wedding
photographer in Rocky Horror
God he had such a weird voice I remember
and then like later he he leaves and he
shakes Brad's hand congratulations
oh I hope that was a put on voice
oh boy
uh
uh let's see
have I heard about Miriam as being in
the Doctor Who's 60th you are the second
person to mention Gaz or maybe you were
the person who mentioned it first I
don't know I did say that I had not
heard prior to this stream I am now
hearing
have I have I finished classic Who uh
technically nobody under the age of
60 has finished classic Who because we
don't have all of it but if you're
asking have I seen all available classic
Doctor Who stories no
no I have not I got a ways to go
uh do I like hot chocolate with
marshmallows yeah sometimes
that's more uh when we actually have
snow on the ground kind of Beverage for
me
sounds like you're doing a Golem
impression there no that wasn't a Golem
impression I can give you a Golem
impression
Julie
that's what's territory precious
we get it
it's precious
uh
stupid fat rabbits
what do I think of musk's Twitter
takeover
[Laughter]
it's a disaster
it's an utter disaster
and I have to laugh because
it's depressing otherwise
the fact that a billionaire was allowed
to take over
what was effectively one of the public
squares of discourse of the world
and run it into the ground in a matter
of
freaking weeks
just because
he wanted to on a whim and even tried to
back out of it he did it anyways
that's actually deeply depressing
but uh
if you're not gonna be depressed about
it you have to laugh
uh
Ace and seven forever agreed uh where's
my jet pack
thank you very much for the Super Chat I
never enjoyed the Dark Knight I don't
know what people see in it the movie is
very slow paced and too serious for my
taste Batman 2022
excuse me is hot
see I think
Heath Ledger carries an awful lot of
that movie it's pretty good otherwise I
personally think but he brings fun to an
otherwise dour movie now it's a dark
kind of fun but he does bring fun to it
uh Supreme
Omega thank you very much unlike Jason I
wonder why Bucky being revived as Winter
Soldier and briefly Captain America has
worked out better is it because Bucky is
more interesting
um yeah
because the thing is
not only is Bucky more interesting as a
character a big part of it is that
Jason dying and staying dead
that was
that was Bruce's failure
he involved a child in his war on crime
and that child died
and him having that on his conscience
him having that in his history
is big
and while the fact that Jason died
doesn't technically go away with the
fact that he came back from the dead it
does diminish the power of that now
Bucky by comparison if I remember
correctly
in the original Comics didn't die on
Mission with cap it was that he died uh
during the time when cap was frozen in
the comics at least but uh in either
case
the loss of Bucky while impacting Steve
was not as integral and as vital to his
character as the loss of Jason Todd was
to Batman that's another part of the
problem
the Gremlins and Golem's voices sound
similar to each other a little bit the
Gremlins are a little raspier
um it's a little bit more nasally see
gollum's voice is very much trapped in
his throat it's down here precious and
the the Gremlins
it sort of way up here as opposed to
down here
it's the difference
um so they're like weird little
differences but it's not deeply
dissimilar uh Stitch is not too far off
from gollum's voice
either so
arhana means famine
family means no one is Left Behind
or forgotten
um so you know Stitch is basically just
Golem without the gurgle
and you'll touch the gurgle
they're kind of get stitched I'm gonna
have to take Stitch and you'll drop him
down into your lower register you end up
with Alan Rickman
the thing is I actually don't have that
[Music]
um
flexible voice but it just kind of shows
like the range of things you can do that
actually aren't that dissimilar from
each other
uh do I have any hopes for Kingdom of
the Planet of the Apes I don't because I
haven't been following it at all
I don't know enough about it to have uh
to have hopes
I can't be totally on board with Jason
have uh having need to stay dead because
I really enjoyed under the Red Hood so
much here okay here's the thing I do
agree with you Angie if he was going to
stay alive
he should have stayed a Villain at least
a villain to Batman if you want to make
a man anti-hero in the sense that you
know he is taking on he's basically
becomes DC's Punisher
um but to Batman he should have stayed a
villain because he then becomes some of
that Batman trained knows Batman's
techniques but is using those techniques
to kill somebody that could have
effectively replaced Batman's failing
with Jason having died with Batman's
failing to not be able to prevent the
things that he showed Jason I do from
being used to kill people but they
didn't even have the strength and
Convention to stick with that so at this
point I consider Jason to be a waste
helps that Golem voice was inspired by
cat coughing up a furball yeah I
remember that
uh
do the Seventh Doctor books written
after the show ended interest me
um or do you not want to see the edgy 90
have their hands on seven I mean
honestly the biggest problem for me is I
um at this point with my ADHD
reading a book is just difficult
if any of them are available as
audiobooks maybe but uh reading books is
really really hard
um
Republicans took the house need to
confirm I'm not surprised they were that
was likely what was going to happen
so yeah
um
jar jar Ed thank you so much
remember when Count Dooku created
Gremlins intelligent enough to make
their own merchandise and branding that
was a trip that happened I love Gremlins
too and not just because it has
Christopher Lee in it though that helps
um I love Gremlins too Gremlins 2 is
amazing and I love I love the brainy
gremlin
I adore that character so much I have I
think he's so fun and he's just this
overly intellectual verbose well-spoken
character but he's still so clearly a
gremlin so like he's being interviewed
and like there's this other little
Gremlin like in a beanie just like
popping up around the chair next to him
and he says well what we want is I think
what everyone wants and what you and
your viewers have civilization the
niceties the fine points diplomacy's
mana's tradition that's what we're
reaching toward we may stumble along the
way but civilization yes
um that's what we aspire to we want to
be civilized now you take a look at this
fellow here just pulls out a gun
now is that civilized no clearly not fun
but in no sense civilized I love I never
get sick of that
Gremlins 2 is so good
and everyone who says the first one's
better is wrong
you're wrong you're just wrong sorry
not sorry you're wrong
ah
Angie p
do you have any advice on where someone
could learn to do voices for d d
purposes okay so here would actually be
my main
thing Angie is if you're not used to
doing vastly different voices what a lot
of DMS have a tendency to do is to try
and come up with
um various accents
so
um you know it's very common to have the
Dolores be Scottish or you know some
approximation of Scottish
um but like not everyone's comfortable
with accents not everyone can do them
well I think a good thing to do
is instead to work on coming up with
different patterns of speech different
cadences different rhythms to talking
for different types of characters so you
can have without having to do an accent
someone who has just a more Regal sense
to them someone who just threw their
voice and the way that they choose to
speak
exudes a sense of superiority or at
least self-superiority
and you can have more laid-back people
who just don't think any of this is a
big deal I mean this guy up on the
throne what's even going on up there I
don't know so I think
um if you're not comfortable doing
massive differentiations in your voice
in terms of pitch or accents just just
work on speech patterns instead
um and and see how that goes
255 A.D did you know musk claims to be a
culture fan I think you mentioned this
before some SpaceX ships are actually
named after gcus
uh what's epitome of not getting a thing
you like yeah
so for people who don't know e m Banks
the culture series I've read three of
those now
um they're really good
any
one like Elon Musk who claims to like
that
it is very much like far-right people
saying that they are Star Trek fans now
granted a lot of the people who say that
they just flatly aren't and never have
been
um because you know they are just trying
to insert themselves into popular
culture and inject their ideas and claim
stuff as their own but like
you run into any Ultra conservative who
does legitimately think they're a fan of
Star Trek my immediate question is how
how
radical to who and what you are
yeah
it's frustrating
personally if I'm Bucky specifically the
MCU version is just as boring why I find
Jason interesting because as someone
with a traumatic upbringing I can relate
to him having PTSD like I I don't think
I don't think there's anything wrong
with liking Jason I don't like Jason I
don't think anyone's wrong to like Jason
it's not like liking the first Gremlins
movie better which is just factually
wrong but you know you can like Jason I
don't all I can offer is the reasons why
I don't especially
I just remembered that alternate panel
for if Jason hadn't died Batman's face
is hilarious it is really weird he's
like holding his body he's like he's
alive
it's yeah no it's not a good look
[Music]
um
mezzo Dave thank you so much for the
Super Chat does the doctor actually have
any children or grandchildren so far as
We Know
yes
we know that the very first doctor uh
William Hartnell
played him you know back when the show
started in the 60s was traveling with
his granddaughter now
it's not impossible
that either Susan was his adopted
granddaughter
or was the daughter of his adopted son
or daughter
but there's nothing
in the
excuse me there's nothing in
the body of the work that
um
that indicates that they are not blood
relatives so we don't know who the
doctor's children were
and how they came about you know in
terms of who the doctor had children
with
but so far as we're aware yeah
I don't really want those holes filled
in any more than they have been
personally
um
if they ever if any writer tried to like
bring any character and be like if this
is the doctor's daughter not like the
episode The Doctor's Daughter which I
don't like anyways but like
daughter from Gallifrey Susan's mother
or something I'd like just leave it
alone
ADHD stands for awesome disorder hot dog
uh
uh let's see
jar jar Ed thank you once more greatly
appreciate that I'm surprised the back
Gremlin never went to Gotham you know
it's funny as a kid I always assumed the
bat Gremlin was how they were going to
do Gremlins three
I always assumed that because he'd just
been encased in cement at some point
he'd be broken out like he'd be knocked
off that church or something and he'd
break out and that would be the start of
Gremlins three
um if Gremlin 3 ever happens which at
this point I doubt it I really doubt it
um but if it ever does that isn't how
how it'll happen but as as a kid
I was so sure that was how they were
going to do Gremlins 3. uh that was how
that's how it would kick off
my favorite Christmas movie
um
it's probably still Love Actually
Christmases all around me
and so the feeling grows
ah
did I ever see Critters the other
noteworthy Creature Feature series from
about small Catholic monsters I did not
ever see Critters I am familiar with it
I never did watch it though
foreign
high voltage thank you do you think
we'll ever escape modern day companions
give me a Jamie or Romana please I hope
so
I hope so I like I'm really
I'm really done we don't need them
anymore just take a just take a break
ah Discord as soon as you catch up on
super chats all right yes
I need to
um pop over the Discord real quick and
see what questions were asked there I
will be back
presently what is that
[Music]
um
here we go
um how do I not stress out about Poland
um I don't know because I have not been
following what's going on in Poland
um my understanding if I remember the
last things that I do remember about
Poland I don't know how you don't stress
out about that
I genuinely don't
um let's see can you explain the
mountain references for Vermont
elections I saw your State's Governor
are all listed as being east or west of
the Green Mountains why is this some
tolkien-esque twist for sooth now it is
it is the turn of the East Mountain
peoples to rule
um the Green Mountains kind of run up uh
middle-ish of the state
uh basically it's it's just it's just a
slight difference of overall mentality
um west of the Green Mountains you tend
to get a little bit more liberal it
borders uh Upstate New York
um east of the Green Mountains you tend
to get comparatively more conservative
and I have to stress comparatively
because even Vermont conservative is not
us conservative
um but east of the Green Mountains you
get a little bit more rural borders New
Hampshire a little bit more
um conservative but that's just a very
generalized thing it's just an easy way
to differentiate the two sides of the
state
um by saying either side of the
mountains
and like it on it's a practical matter
it doesn't have a lot of meaning anyway
because we got mountains all over this
damn state
you know the Green Mountains are a
specific range but like there's a reason
we call pretty much anybody who's not
from here Flatlanders you you will never
find a mile long stretch of flat ground
that has not been created by humans
do you think Colin Baker could continue
to rise up in your doctor rankings the
more big finish stories I hear I think
we've really lost one of the great
doctors it's possible as possible big
finish could really uh shake these
things up have you eaten uh turducken no
um but a couple of thanksgivings ago
my kid's mother made
a pie cake in
I'm trying to remember it was like
it was like a cake inside of a pie
inside of another pie
I forget exactly what everything was but
there was a pie cake in I did have a
piece of that it was a lot
um you said you thought uh a John II was
a monster he is a monster but he's uh is
he a monster is is he just insanely
privileged teen boy who thinks he's
entitled to do whatever he wants because
of the life he's lived uh like you
compared him to Joffrey but I think a
major difference is Joffrey actively
takes pleasure in hurting others I think
hey I don't think Asia aegon likes
hurting people he just does because
that's what happens if you decide to do
whatever you want and have a lot of
power
so
so we're talking about House of the
Dragon
Dragon
um aegon is a monster
is he a monster on the scale of Joffrey
no but it's not a binary
you don't have to be as bad as the worst
person ever to be a monster
you don't have to be Jeffrey Dahmer to
be a monster you don't have to be Adolf
Hitler to be a monster
he is a monster whether he's a monster
by nature or by the circumstances that
he lives in I don't really care
I care about who he is and how he
behaves and the kind of person that he
shows himself to be
and I think he's a monster
I'm not saying that the reasons why
people are what they are don't matter
but I am going to say that when I am
assessing my opinion of them I don't
care
I don't I care about who you are and
what you are doing
and your reason for doing it for me
that's academic it has no use Beyond
just my academic understanding of things
in terms of my assessment of you as a
human being if I think you are doing
bad things and I believe you understand
that these are bad things
I don't care if it's because of
privilege I don't care if it's because
of crossed wires in your head I don't
really care what it is
I'm going to judge you on your actions
yeah he's a monster
um because of Artemis recently my autism
special interest has been rocket
launches something I noticed if you look
through a list of all the launches at
Cape Canaveral you only see a minority
of them are space probes or scientific
satellites significantly higher portion
of them our military satellites that are
being sent up to do stuff like spy on
other countries
if you were one of the engineers that
worked there how would you feel about
the ethics of that could you personally
justify helping the American Empire if
you also occasionally get to help send
stuff uh that'll push science forward
I'm not in a really in a position to
answer that because like that entire
line of work is just something I would
never get into
just like because of my interests are if
I were to try and put myself in that
headspace
I could imagine at an earlier point of
my life thinking it was worth it but
probably by this point of my life having
to quit
because the ethics didn't make sense
anymore
and that's not because the situation
would have changed but I would have
changed
in the first Owl House special there's a
bit where the cast reminisce about
bonding in the times we didn't see
because they didn't get a full season I
didn't like that because
uh it's an Fu Disney that they won't
care about and will make no sense to
people particularly kids who don't
follow the behind the scenes stuff like
want the effect of putting that just be
kids seeing thinking oh this sucks why
didn't you show us all that stuff
without understanding uh it was out of
the production team's control I disagree
I think it depends on the kid some of
them maybe but
you need to understand my perspective I
come at this as somebody who is
always been used to having holes in my
knowledge of things part of that comes
from the fact that growing up you know I
didn't have TV coming into the house and
so even shows I really liked
um you know they were they'd be taped
you know all out of order
um you know just be Random episodes of
things that I like that my grandmother
taped for me and sent and sent to me
so I got very used very early on to
having holes and just assuming oh well
that happened in a bit I haven't seen so
it's hard for me to to try and put my
head in the space of someone for whom
that would matter
so like yes maybe it would bother some
people but like I think just by virtue
of the fact that I got by
um with a lot of holes and a lot of my
understanding of a lot of things but
still taking enjoyment out of them I
think that shows that like for some
people it won't matter
so I don't think it was an inherently
wrong thing to do
um people will react differently
uh
uh What uh is my favorite way to cook
eggs
it's super mood dependent like
my favorite way to cook like as a cook
and scramble I like cooking scrambled
eggs that's fun
um you know fried eggs
um getting them at just the right
consistency is a little more stressful
um and the yolks breaking and all that
so I don't like cooking fried eggs I do
like eating fried eggs but I don't
particularly like cooking them
um I tend to do kind of a medium boil
egg these days which I rather like I'll
put I'll put that in with uh with uh
fresh Ramen I say fresh it's bagged with
Ramen I'm acting fan like oh I'm
physically like fresh Ramen I don't it's
from a bag I just add
um green onion and
uh medium boiled eggs to it to feel like
I'm having something better than just
packed Ramen
I forgotten have you played stardew
Valley do you like it I did start
playing it that was months ago though I
haven't gotten back to it not because I
disliked it but because I hadn't I
didn't have time to like fully get into
the groove of it
um and I just haven't I just haven't had
the time to revisit it so that's where
that is all right I am back in the main
chat now
let's see
uh 255 A.D Discord yes I did get there
uh jar jar Ed the doctor's child is
obviously Mary Poppins who later travels
back in time changed her names and met
doc Emmett Brown in 1885.
that's decent enough head Cannon uh and
one more from jar jar Ed clearly
scrambled eggs with ketchup is the best
it was
30 years ago for me uh when I do
scrambled eggs at this point I don't
just do scrambled eggs I put a lot in
that scramble I'll put you know either
sausage or ham
um I will put
[Music]
um
uh tomato I will put a green onion
um
yeah and I'll put cheese and like but
I'm not doing it as an Amic an omelette
I'm trying to fold it together as an
omelette but um just throwing that stuff
into a scramble I really like
what are my thoughts on Plague dogs and
waterships down I haven't seen play dogs
Watershed down I've seen
um I think I think I just if it was
gonna grab me I probably need to see it
earlier than I did it's a it's a heck of
a thing I'll give it that
uh speaking of Gremlins to the Abe
Lincoln lookalike story
it's much more effed up than the Santa
one
it
potentially like they cut her off
before it goes further so
we don't know
um if it's how effed up that story ends
up being it has the potential to be
worse though yeah
Supremo Mega thank you very much I know
the 90s had issues but 2000's DC is not
better with Legacy Heroes and Sidekicks
got killed Sidelines turned evil or have
their lives destroyed yeah
DC
uh DC has been a disaster
since the late 90s
I mean the mid 90s weren't great for it
either but
I think the late 90s was when it started
to take a direction that it
wouldn't ever pull out of so
yeah
oh hey JVL good to see you have I read
any of the atomic Robo and how can I get
you hooked on it I mean the holidays are
coming up if you want to send me a
volume I will try and get around to it
uh I have not read it as such
Russia accidentally hit
Poland
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
I missed that
God
damn it
oh God damn it
yeah I saw that you mentioned Poland
earlier homebody the problem was I
didn't know what had happened
um I knew like some other stuff over the
past year or so that's kind of been
going on going on with Poland
politically I didn't realize
I did not realize that that
had
happened
oh
wow
um
Bottoms Up
God damn it
do I like mayonnaise on my chips I'm
assuming you mean fries so chips in the
British sense
um straight up mayonnaise no
garlic mayonnaise or as it will usually
be pegged around here because so people
won't realize what they're eating garlic
aioli yeah sure
uh
have I seen Chucky I have not I've
actually not seen I've I've only ever
seen two of those movies all the way
through bride and Seed I've never seen
any of the Child's Play movies and I
haven't seen any episodes of the show
uh
uh at this point I'm willing to accept
the possibility of Patrick from
SpongeBob being in charge of the Russian
military
sorry Poland I can't really do a Patrick
voice I don't know what I was trying to
do I was like a weird old man thing I
don't know what that was
uh I should call it a stream
[Laughter]
[Music]
good grief
uh
what are my thoughts on the Austin
Powers franchise I have not rewatched
any of those movies in ages
I suspect I I to my memory the first one
is really the only good one the third
one's better than people say it is and
the second one is trash
such trash
holy crap it's real bad that second
one's so bad it's so bad
it's awful
ah
anyways
uh I'm gonna wrap it up
uh uh oh I I missed one
um
Super Chat from jar Jared
me
some mean at the end of Back to the
Future Part three docs responds to go
back to the future is no reason already
been there
um
I mean yeah that fits with what you said
before
um
I mean how however you want to fit all
these things together
uh so uh stuff going on tomorrow
um I will be streaming
I
don't know what
um I might let me see here
uh
crap
um
I don't know I don't know what I'm gonna
stream I might just throw on Hades
um
and go with that I don't know
but I will be streaming uh tomorrow
morning uh 10 30 Eastern Time
and then later tomorrow will be the
Andor review in the break room and then
the wakanda forever review on
Thursday
and Saturday's video in uh right here on
the council Geeks will be a re-ranking
of the Masters since I already did
excuse me the doctors
and also I'll be streaming again Friday
morning
I'll get hiccups ah
hi
uh I hope well I'm glad you came thanks
for being here thanks for spending time
with me I hope you have a great
rest of the day rest of the week
holiday season
whatever it is I hope you have a good
one
be well
be safe be kind you are beautiful you
are valid
and you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meeting and until next time this council
is adjourned
mccavity